flippy from
indiana flippy from indiana please
unmute you are on the air my friend
all right can you hear me yes i can hey
david it's me
um i just was wondering if you've ever
reconsidered making it only fans sorry
if i if i've done
making an omelette what no no making it
only fans uh you know
uh burning season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
[Music]
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith afros than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
ladies and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
stand back and stand by
[Music]
let's please continue on person woman
man camera tv
[Music]
that's amazing how did you do that
[Music]
a good memory because i'm cognitively
[Music]
there
[Music]
what is going on here we won't talk
about toilets
[Music]
if my grandmother had wheels instead of
legs
orange oranges she would be a bicycle
god bless the united states thank you
very much
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed it is trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
[Music]
as opposed to
[Music]
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what
[Music]
what is going on here what is going on
dump big massive dumps
[Music]
all right just a perfect song there from
uh officer akimov as we know him and we
boy do we have a stream for you today
here's the agenda for today okay i am
going to tell you
about getting duped today on something
that's actually it's
it's pretty harmless and it's it's funny
so we're going to talk about that i got
duped
we're going to talk about marjorie
taylor green being expelled
from the uh committees she's on on the
house of representatives
she gave a um bonkers
a completely outrageous cuckoo for coco
puffs to even call it a press conference
stretches the
definition of the english language but
she gave a completely insane press
conference this morning so we're going
to talk about that
then mike lindell remember how mike
lindell
on friday was scheduled to give us all
the proof about
voter fraud he did it today and it was
so crazy that even oan
had to run a completely incredible
disclaimer
before airing this thing so we're gonna
look at that i'm not gonna look at the
whole thing because it's like 40 minutes
long
but aaron our friend aaron rupar over at
vox took the
went through the trouble of highlighting
some of the crazier elements from the
mike lindell
situation so we're going to go through
that that i mean this is just this is a
perfect stream we have so
much then i have two to four troy york
voicemails
um to play maybe for you guys uh one of
them left under the moniker wally
jackson
the other um who even knows what names
troy yorke is using at this point so
we've got that
then this is unbelievable
jimmy dore interviewed this guy rod
weber recently
after jimmy interviewed a boogaloo boy
and seemed to think that the boogaloo
boys are like some kind of far left
social justice warriors or something
like that
and it went disastrously for jimmy dore
jimmy dore actually started
um uh treated his guest like nothing
i've ever seen
and jimmy never published it but rod had
the
foresight to record the entire interview
on his end
and it is like nothing i have seen
before jimmy actually claims the cia
is doing something to him it's actually
to the point where i've suspected for a
while
like i've stayed away from the jimmy
door stuff for a while
jimmy dore i know i've stayed away from
it because i thought that he's been sort
of unwell
much like i thought about glenn
greenwald and this i think proves it
because he seems to believe um
that the cia is doing something to him
you know i mean it's it's crazy
and then wait what else did i have
i have my list here uh oh oh oh
and then i want to go over the the plan
for trump's second impeachment trial
next week
and talk about what to uh what to do
there so let me just jump right into
some things and and before i do that
i i do uh thanks to polo dal for the sub
401 kelly
bowflex man uh huge the huge
geoventure all sorts of amazing people
signing up via twitch and uh oh and
that's the oh that's the last thing
if we do get we've been we've been
failing a little bit on the member goals
lately
i will also open up phone lines if we
get to a hundred so we're already five
in from the standpoint of twitch
also thanks to jaron chevy and
aj ello who just signed up at
joinpakman.com putting us at seven
okay so that'll be the last thing if we
do get to a hundred
in the course of going over all of these
different uh news stories and elements
we we will open up some phone lines
all right so let me get right into the
the first thing
i got hilariously duped today i'm
basically being taken
out of uh we've had to put in a plan
with our discord moderators where they
are now going to be vetting moderators
because i i just
i have so many things going on and i'm
sort of naive that i did something
really stupid today
many of you may know the name ronald ray
gun like a ray gun you understand
um who's been a caller to this show and
to sam cedar's show
he's an attorney he's a friend of the
progressive media community ronald
reagan
i got an email from someone saying hey
it's ronald reagan here
i'm hanging out in your discord already
i would love to moderate
and i thought i we love ray gun let's
absolutely let's do it we'll put ray gun
and so i made ray gun a moderator on the
david pakman show discord which now has
like 11 or 12
000 like it's a it's a nicely it's it's
a psy it's a plump discord right it's
sizeable
and i i make him a moderator people can
already tell where this is going
and i go into our moderator only channel
i say let's welcome ronald reagan of you
know
calling into the david pakman show ray
gun doesn't even know about this if he's
watching he's going to learn about this
and great we've got another moderator we
needed and within a few
minutes or maybe 20 minutes or something
i start getting messages from our
moderators saying
that's not ray gun it's a 15 year old
kid
and they're they're saying really
inappropriate things and we've gotta
we've got to get uh we've got to do
something about that
so i immediately went in and not only
de-modded this kid but
um but banned him as well and
now two of our moderators are taking
this process out of my hands
and i've been told they will vet new
moderators on the discord i have been
stripped of that duty because clearly i
can't
uh i am unable to discharge my duty
properly
when it comes to vetting moderators so
that happened today
and thankfully no harm done just a
little bit a little bit humiliating
okay so uh yeah i they ran the my own
moderators
have uh 25th amendment to me
and uh i'm out i am no longer so now the
process is anybody who wants to mod
i pass it along they will research for
funny business
and that's going to be and by the way
they were made moderators not
administrators so i see people saying oh
you got
you know it's only it's only moderators
not administrators all right so that's
the ray gun thing so we've gotten that
out of the way
okay a few super chats any chance we see
trump testify
i don't think so no z fisher says you
play left back
on our ps4 fifa 21 soccer club and you
kind of suck
jimmy dore plays midfield he's a bit
more aggressive interesting all right
jared says hello david it's been a while
since econ 101 but my understanding was
presidents don't really do things that
impact the economy on a macro level
and macro is more important than micro
am i wrong yes you're wrong
presidents don't do anything that impact
the economy on a micro level
uh arguably through tax policy maybe in
some in some way
uh no i think you were wrong david i had
a dream the other night where you were
in a car together and you crashed it
yikes i hope it was an electric car at
least david does your shirt
wick moisture i don't know it's wool
does wool wick moisture i don't know
um and where do i get the video from
mike lindell
just google it google it it's out there
oan published it
you have the best soundtrack david as a
fellow drummer i must know your
influences and what genres you like to
play what kind of kit do you play
i have a mapex kit but i've
i'm mostly working on a roland roland v
drums now just for
from the standpoint of volume it's a
little bit safer
all right guys let's get right into um
some of this other stuff that we've got
going on
uh before i do that 2292 thanks to the
five
folks who just grabbed twitch
subscriptions and
also thanks to hail hawthorne who just
signed up at joinpakman.com
i will open phone lines if we get to a
hundred all right let's get right into
it this is yesterday the house voting to
expel marjorie taylor green
from her committee assignments on this
vote
the yeas are 230 and the nays are 199
the resolution is adopted
without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table
so there it is marjorie taylor green
expelled from her committee assignments
this morning she gave what is being
called
a press conference and i'm just not sure
if that's the right term let's just get
into it
hello it's recording it's recording here
no it's recording yeah it's going down
thank you for letting me know well first
off thank you all for uh
thank you for coming out here today and
being willing to hear what i have to say
um she she's absolutely repulsive i mean
it's i have a visceral reaction to her
it's it's i find this woman disgusting
in every way
i just want you to know that for the
press
i i truly support freedom of press
i think it's one of the things that
makes our country so great
and and again that's one of those things
where like it's meaningless you know we
have a first amendment
what does it mean that she it's sort of
like saying i support the rules of
gravity
what what okay but it's you who are you
we have a first amendment in this
country um i really hope that you'll be
able to tell my story a little bit
better
instead of just reporting and repeating
uh
maybe some things that you don't like
about me or things that were on social
media in 2018.
you see the reason why i ran for
congress is because
i really don't respect what our
government has become
as just an ordinary american someone
who's had to work hard all my life
someone who's been married for almost 25
years and raised three kids
like how is it relevant how many kids
she has or
her marriage when she's talking about
jewish space lasers denying 911
saying you can't swear an oath on a
quran how what i i don't care if she has
20 kids or none i got to tell you
my three kids are the greatest part of
my life
that's the best thing i've ever done is
to be a mom okay
i really love our country i love our
freedoms and i
sincerely want all of your children
my children and all of us to continue to
have the opportunity to have the
american dream
but our government is failing us
you see we're approaching nearly 30
trillion dollars in debt
oh my god dad i told you guys
when when biden won which we knew on
november 8th by the way
i know some people were like oh no
december 14th and then safe harbor
no we knew on november 8th i said these
republicans who haven't cared about the
debt and deficit under trump they're
going to start talking about the debt
and here's the debt what about the
jewish space laser margie
as a successful business owner for over
20 years if i ran my company
the way this government runs and spends
in waste and puts us in debt with our
own hard-earned tax dollars
i'd be out of business a long time ago
the country isn't a business
the country isn't a household any
analogies
can households print money can
households
uh uh affect the economy-wide interest
rate
can households take actions that affect
um
uh trade this is it's idiotic the in any
analogy between a household budget
or a business budget these are
ridiculous analogies
and we'd be homeless on the streets but
it's much worse than that for decades
now
this government has sold out our
american worker
sent our jobs overseas to foreign
populist rhetoric again unrelated to why
she was expelled
we've opened our borders wide open to be
flooded
with illegals no we haven't that's
that's just not true
coming indoors it's weird because trump
just finished running on how
undocumented immigration was down to a
record low
is she arguing that in the last 14 days
under biden it's now
the borders are open i mean like what is
she even arguing because
she supported the guy who says it's the
lowest it's been in a long time
our country think about kate steinle who
was murdered on a pier
in california she died in her father's
arms
krisha odette her father served our
country four tours
four tours in the middle east
protecting our freedoms when he came
back home his daughter this is crazy
killed by an illegal alien in texas
these are the things that shouldn't
happen
but these are the policies that are
allowed and continued
our country has made it legal
and funded with our tax dollars over 62
million is this about abortions is this
where she's going
abortions murdering god's creation in
the womb
that is a sin a dis her response to
being removed from committees should get
her removed from the house
disgusting evil that is unfathomable
i can't even believe that it continues
but here's the thing
all of these women that have gone
through that it leaves a hole
in their soul that never heals how can
she speak to how every woman who's ever
had an abortion
feels it's ridiculous it's insulting
what is she talking about and those
women have been taught that this is the
way that they should achieve
this is the way they can build a career
this is a way
that they can solve the problem that
they didn't want in the first place
that's a horrible lie i don't even know
what argument she's making now
terrible lie as a mother and a woman
who's had a successful career
i can tell you being a mom is the
greatest gift of my life
i really hope that america it's weird
because she's she just was talking about
freedom
and now she's saying her view on
motherhood should be
imposed on every woman
what and end the evil of abortion
i also want you to know that free speech
matters
free speech really matters and yesterday
when the democrats
and 11 of my republican colleagues
decided to strip me of my committee
assignments
education and labor and the budget
committee yeah you know what they did
they actually stripped my district of
their voice
no they didn't you still represent that
district at least until november of
2020.
does anybody who's not on the committee
not represent their constituents that's
an idiotic argument
they stripped my voters of having
representation
to work for them for the budget that's
so so
so basically only the only people who
have representation on budget
are people whose elected officials are
on that committee
so that means most of the country is
unrepresented when it comes to budget
this is a deplorable woman
a successful business owner that knows
how to make a profit
not a loss yeah we need we need more
business approaches brought into
government we saw how well that went
with trump
that's what my district voted for me for
i'm a mom
with three kids who has taken my
children to gun-free school zones
their entire time they went to school
and when i was in 11th grade at 16 years
old when joe biden
created gun-free school zones one of my
schoolmates
brought three guns to school on a school
bus and a duffel bag
brought them into the school in the
first period class because he was very
upset
at two of his classmates and none of the
other kids had guns to defend themselves
with thanks to joe biden
he pulled out his weapon went to take
control
the coach in the classroom knocked him
to the floor but he was able to reach in
and get
another one of his guns fired his weapon
took control of our school
and we were held hostage in our
classrooms for five hours
i want you to know i know that fear that
david hogg felt
it's terrifying is she talking about the
fear when she was chasing him around or
the fear
at the parkland school it's terrifying
when the only person
in the building with a gun is very upset
and is there to do evil and there's no
good guy
with any guns to protect us that's why
when i was in washington i could go from
senate office to senate office just like
david hogg and say
vote no to gun control because we need
our second amendment rights
we need to be able to protect our
children with good guys with guns
just like the people up here what has
happened protected themselves with
30 000 national guard troops
the troops were there to protect people
from trumpist rioters
imagine that they want to leave our
children defenseless
but they will surround this place with a
big beautiful border wall
and a whole bunch of good guys with guns
see these are the policies that disgust
me
these are the policies that discuss guys
i'm not going to lie i don't know that i
can do another 15 minutes of this
just the american people and these are
the policies of hypocrites
you see when the people in charge want
to just spend your money and spend your
money and you have no choice but to give
it to them
and believe me i've been a good taxpayer
for years now
and i always will be and then they want
to send our hard-earned dollars
over to is she good does any is
has anybody who's watched this can you
tell me whether she actually addresses
like the things she was expelled from
committees for saying does it does
is that is there any point at which she
actually talks about that foreign
nations
and so-called foreign aid to fund things
like border walls
and bridges and schools and roads and
abortion that's nothing she doesn't oh
boy
should stay here in america oh she
answers questions dollars should fund
our border wall our bridges our schools
our roads she calls on oan all right
homeless they should help
our people i'll stick with it our
forgotten our orphans
our foster care children that's what our
hard-earned tax dollars should be doing
not what these people here have been
doing for decades
the those that are in charge have been
here for decades
decades do you know the average age of
retirement it's around 64
65 years old in the private sector
but not here in congress they cling to
power
as long as they can you can actually
hear military drills in the background
because apparently it's addictive and
they can't give it up
that's fair yeah let's speed it up to
1.25 at least to chop a little time off
of it
something that i just can't tolerate i
can't take it
and the american people are so sick of
it you see a record number of americans
voted for president trump
record number of republicans voted for
president trump do you want to know why
it's because they loved his policies
they loved his fight
they loved the fact that for once we had
a president that stood up for america
stood up for american businesses and
remembered the forgotten man
he was a president that didn't care
about your skin color because god
created us all equal
this is so nuts like she still hasn't
addressed why she got kicked out of the
committees
thank god our constitution affirms that
he was a president that wanted every
single person to achieve
and that's why we supported him that's
why i've always supported him
and when i tell you republican voters
support him still
the party is his it doesn't belong to
anybody else
this impeachment trial that's going to
happen next week
it's a circus that allows media
companies to get lots of clicks
lots of views and sell ad dollars and
you know what
that's pretty disgusting too everyone
here knows that he did not cause this
attack on the capitol
nor did i nor did any republican but the
responsibility falls squarely on those
that invaded the capitol
uh-oh cue a mom is starting to ferment
ones that planned it ahead of time
those are the people that should be held
accountable i was in the chamber
unlike aoc representative ocasio-cortez
that faked her outrage with another hoax
just another hoax that gets shared
everywhere
you see those kind of fake lies
like aoc fake lies representative cory
bush telling people that i attacked her
when in fact it was on video that she
attacked me this is the kind of fake
outrage that is dividing
our congress along with a fake outrage
on the news every single day
that's dividing our people i don't know
guys uh i was glad she was kicked off
the committees but after seeing this
it's making me doubt whether that was
the right decision she sounds totally
reasonable
you know what the media does and you
guys are great at it and i'm telling you
this because
i want to like you but you're doing a
really good job at addicting our nation
to hate
teaching people to hate people like me
president trump
and then on the right it's the same way
teaching people to hate aoc
ilhan omar nancy pelosi see it goes both
ways doesn't it
well she's doing that she went into the
halls of congress and tried to demand
that uh ilhan omar wreath swear an oath
on a bible
rather than the quran that came from a
place of love of course
to it is killing our country it's
causing people to no longer be friends
families to no longer talk to each other
even husband and wives getting divorced
parents not talking to their children
and the other way around
i think that's terrible and it's
shameful
when you have such a platform as you
have
what do you want your legacy to be do
you want your legacy to be the platform
that destroyed our nation and cause our
people to hate one another
or would you rather be a platform that
told the truth because you're given the
great gift
the freedom of press so that you can
tell the truth
yeah right after i like the super chat
right after this press conference she
went back in and asked to speak to the
manager of congress about the expulsion
love for you to be that platform and i
would be so proud of you
i wouldn't be mad at any of you i had
the greatest opportunity
yesterday and i'm so grateful for it i
got to say what i had done wrong
and do you know how freeing that is and
what was that i'm not kidding
i seriously feel blessed by god because
i got to do it on a world stage
i got to say i said things wrong i
believe things that were wrong
and you know what you know i'm i'm so
happy i got to do that my district is
thrilled with me
people all over the country are thankful
and supporting me country loves you
i'm grateful to them none of us are
perfect and when
when we go about our life thinking that
we are we're such hypocrites
truthfully we really are if we think
we're perfect we can judge one another
that's such a mistake so
going forward i like how she's going
into the conclusion phase but so far she
still hasn't actually
said anything i've been freed i do i
feel free because you know what's
happening on these committees liberated
we have a basically a tyrannically
controlled government right was she
doing the i didn't i don't even want to
be on the committees anyway take it take
your ball and go home
the democrats we've got joe biden
writing executive order after executive
order sign him sign him sign him
doing whatever he wants up there in the
white house we have nancy pelosi leading
the democrats in congress to do whatever
the bail bond links to get the criminals
out of jail
but they want to kick me off committees
for social media posts she mistakenly
believed that the jews controlled the
lasers when it was really only
hasidic jews and she incorrectly
included reform
and conservative jews in that that were
conspiracy theories
that's pretty hypocritical you see the
american people won't forget
because they're still reeling from the
devastation of this past year
where cities were burned people were
attacked police officers still dealing
with it
attacked night after night they take
that home with them and it hurts their
families
occupying federal buildings taking over
police precincts
so much damage tearing down statues and
monuments erasing our history
this is what when's the last time a
statue or monument was was
even damaged this happened
i do not condone what happened on
january other than what trump is did at
the capitol of course
46. it was one of the scariest days of
my life next to being held hostage in a
gun-free school zone
when one of my students one of my fellow
students took it over with a gun and no
one protected us no one could
it was terrible
so i'm going to ask all of you think
about what you report who
is this who is she to tell the media how
to behave
this woman has no idea about anything
when you're on the news
calling riot's peaceful protest the
american people
are disgusted with you because you're
lying that's what trump did at every
single one of his
uh rallies didn't he when you're
promoting
people that protect these things and
want to continue it
people are sick of it they're fed up
because they lost their businesses
and they may have gotten hurt and
they're tired of being attacked because
they want to wear a red hat that says
make america great again
or they voted for trump and we're proud
of it
things have got to change and i tell you
again
i'm fine with being kicked off in my
committees because it'd be a waste of my
time
she didn't want him anyway very hard
worker and i'm proud of it
so now i have a lot of free time on my
hands which means
i can talk to a whole lot more people
all over this country
and i can talk to more people and make
connections and build
a huge amount of support that i've
already got started with people that
want to put america first and don't care
about the party lines
and don't care about any of the
political identities who is she talking
about
involved and that's something that i am
very excited about
so i look forward to going home and
seeing people in my district
i'm thankful and overwhelmed by their
support i'm grateful
that i had the opportunity to say the
things that i don't believe
and i shouldn't have said in the first
place and i'm really grateful to my god
because
he forgives me and that's what being a
christian is all about
i have a message to other christians in
this country right don't be lukewarm
that's not what your faith is for our
savior died on a cross so your sins can
be forgiven and he
oh my goodness he doesn't want you to be
quiet about it he wants you to share the
gospel
and share it with everyone that being
said
i'm going to let you guys go about your
day i know you got many things yeah i'll
take some questions
but i know you talked yesterday i
listened to your speech but you said on
a video in january of 2019 i'm just
going to read it to you
and you said it's been taken out who are
you what's your name
by our law representatives and senators
can be kicked out and no longer serve in
our government
let me actually go to 1x just so we can
really hear the questions now this i
actually want to hear this the crime
punishable
by death is what treason is what you
think did you see but did you see my
speech yesterday i
how many how many stories did you report
on russian collusion conspiracy lies
no i wanted to she's not answering okay
so have you apologized for russian
collision conspiracy lies
have you see it's like why does the
reporter have to answer her
questions she's she decided to take
questions why is she asking the reporter
questions
i want you to be able to i don't have to
so she thinks she doesn't have to answer
questions she's here on a press
conference but she doesn't have to
answer questions
oh wow the fact that you said nancy
pelosi is guilty of treason
i think you heard my speech yesterday
you owe the people an apology you lied
about president trump
you owe the people an apology i've done
mine yesterday mental illness okay
next question
what do you see as your role here going
forward
basically just to do things like this
all is the job i got elected to do
um i'm gonna vote very conservative
pro-life
pro-second amendment pro-border
american businesses pro economy pro jobs
she'll be out of a job in 22 months
right i mean if she's not then the
country's really screwed
need to reopen this country we need to
put kids back in schools
keeping them at home is killing our
children well that's joe biden's plan
depression is high suicide's high we
canceled prom canceled graduation
canceled their lives i'm going to be
working hard on those policies
and i'm going to be holding the
republican party accountable and pushing
them to the right
it's funny to talk about how pro-life
she is she hasn't mentioned the actual
virus that's killing 4 000 people a day
other at all other than to say we need
to reopen everything
what do you say to those 11. thank you
jenn pellegrino with oen
you mentioned aoc and i wanted to ask
you about that this question i'm
guessing she'll like because it's from
oan
your supporters commonly know you as mtg
there's a lot of comparisons that could
be made as a freshman in congress making
waves
receiving positive and negative
attention on both sides of the aisle
would you say that perhaps uh you've
maybe scared democrats uh in the media
as well and this year yeah
aoc when she stepped on the scene that
kind of made waves among republicans
i'd say there's a comparison between us
and and the fact that we really don't
care
what other people think about us because
i can say that for myself i've never met
her but i assume she probably feels that
way
um but there's a major difference in us
aoc embraces policies of
socialism to what you could call
communism yes so
yeah absolutely give us what now just
just i'm sure you have a list of
marjorie
what's the list of communist policies
that aoc is advocating for
she wants to have she wants to have all
the power
and the people that she claims she wants
to help her policies would reduce them
to poverty
right and they wouldn't have many
freedoms left so there's a big
difference than
us um i support our constitution and all
of our freedoms
and i'll work very hard against her
policies and one more question
yes one more question is this a second
oan question in a row
using her this morning on twitter and he
said here there's no remote
remorse just a huge desire to be famous
what do you say to him and the other 10
republicans that voted against uh
or voted for removing you from the
committee well there were 10 that
that voted for impeachment against
president trump and they definitely paid
the price they heard from republican
voters
there were 11 that voted against me
yesterday um and that that's something
that our leaders should
be very upset about kevin mccarthy and
the rest of the republican party is
working hard on taking back the majority
and when you have republicans in the
ranks voting against one of their own
opening the door for democrats to go
after every single republican next
that that really is a big portrait and
that could cost us
at this point i'm going to keep going
because there's only two minutes but
majority in 22.
people are very angry that's all i've
heard from people all morning furious
about that so
i hope that my republican colleagues
really
think about what they've done i'm sure
they're going to hear from their voters
at home because the base is loyal to
president trump
and the base has been very loyal to me
and they've shown me that
my question is is there anything
that you haven't said that you now want
to
say i'm sorry for not just you regret or
walk back
but is there anything you are sorry for
saying in the past
oh of course i'm sorry for saying all
those things that are wrong and
offensive
and and i sincerely mean that and i'm
i'm happy to say that i think it's good
to say
say when we've done something wrong so
yeah that's what that's easy
which things though
are you sorry to david hogg what you
said to him
[Music]
david hogg was an adult when i talked to
him i don't think any of you have
realized that david hogg
was working with the organization that
was
they were going around working hard the
shooting victim she bullied was
legally an adult guys it's fine
how dare you criticize what she did four
strict gun control laws i'm very opposed
to those policies
and so being in the same situation as
david hogg my voice matters too
oh she's a victim like david hogg oh
that's interesting
thanks frank for gifting 10 subs i
appreciate that and so
no i'm not sorry for telling him he
shouldn't push for gun control
what we need to do is we need to protect
our children i think you're expecting
we should protect our our children and
and your baby as well
um with good guys with guns and not
allow them to be sitting there sitting
ducks yeah
thank you you talked earlier about the
media teaching people to hate but wasn't
it you who like to
page on facebook and comments saying
nancy pelosi should get a bullet to
their heads
and did you know this reminds me of when
you guys would ask president trump
president trump he really wants to be
just like trump do you denounce white
supremacy
and he would say i denounce it and then
you would ask him again and he would
have to say
i denounced it yesterday i mentioned i
have said it
specifically you know here's here's the
thing
when you stand back and stand by you
want to keep telling the same story
over and over but you don't want to tell
the truth that's your problem
and that's how we end press conferences
my god so i guess five questions
two from oan and uh all right so there's
uh there's marjorie taylor green
so that's that's that we made it through
it we made it through it and i guess
that's um very nice nice to do uh
okay big uh thank you let me get caught
up
on folks who signed up um thanks for the
17 twitch subs including 10 gifted by
frank
also on our website i want to say thank
you to
cesar labarca who just signed up at
joinpackman.com
and jane bacon jane bacon also signing
up putting us at 32. i've got a whole
agenda of things to to talk about today
but if when i'm done we're at a hundred
website members and twitch subs we'll
open the phone lines a little bit
and uh of course the coupon code better
21 is working
i got a couple emails yesterday from
people saying david you know i think the
reason people are saying it's not
working
is it's case sensitive and it's not case
sensitive if you want to type in better
21 in all caps
beautiful if you want to type in better
21 all in little
letters li ddle little uh that works
if you want to alternate capital and
lowercase it is not
case sensitive that is not the that is
not the issue
walt says via super chat
at no point in your rambling incoherent
response
were you even close to anything that
could be considered a rational thought
everyone in this room is now dumber for
having listened to it i award you no
points and may god have mercy on your
soul
i don't know if walt's talking about me
or marjorie taylor greene
i actually can't tell if this super chat
is attacking me or attacking her
thanks for sharing this i wish i arrived
earlier do you think green believes
anything she says
yeah that's one of the scariest things
about green which is
i think she's really not this nuts i
think she does believe everything she
says and that's really really scary
okay so we've got that so do you guys
want me to do
my pillow mike lindell insanity
jimmy dore insanity or voicemails what
are what are people looking for next
does anybody feel strongly about we're
doing all of it it's just a question of
the order
people seem to be pushing for jimmy dore
okay let's do that
all right here's the deal this this is
really really stunning stuff
okay i'm gonna we have to really explain
this
so rod weber rod weber
was uh interviewed by jimmy dore
in 2016 i'll just go through the threat
okay jimmy dore interviewed me in 2016
but it never
aired this time i went on to talk about
my new film
even after he berated me i used kid
gloves
10 days of excuses from jimmy dore let's
have that honest discussion about tucker
carlson tim poole
and kyle rittenhouse now so what what
rod weber did is is smart and listen
i've had people do this with me
they usually tell me like when i
interviewed sam harris sam harris told
me i'm going to record this on my end
and i said beautiful that's fine
uh we don't do any edits we're not going
to cut it we're going to air it exactly
as it took place
i'm glad for you to record it on your
end beautiful no
no problem so um rod weber was able to
do that himself
and let's just look at this first clip
let me make sure we have audio i want to
make sure everybody hears it this is
really crazy
his latest movie is called 2020 the
dumpster fire
it's rod weber how representative do you
think that that guy that i
interviewed and by the what the the
subject is
that jimmy interviewed someone from the
boogaloo boys
and thought that um and thought that it
was like a great guy i guess
representative of the boogaloos if you
look to uh
say unicorn riots uh leaked
a chat from uh discords you can hear
them in their own voice
very many of them saying all kinds of
racist things
um so i i i i have to say
that that there is some merit to what
what people are saying
um i mean you know first and foremost i
would even say
you need to start talking more [ __ ]
about tucker colson and his rants about
uh his uh
uh white nationalism you need to be
talking [ __ ] about tim paul
rod don't do that
we're not talking about [ __ ] tucker
carlson we're not talking about [ __ ] i
should be doing
we're talking about this [ __ ] guy and
the boogaloo boys
i'm not talking what the [ __ ] are you
doing okay well then uh
i i i would never dream of treating a
guest like this
i've interviewed people who
are open um uh white supremacists
i i would never treat any guest in this
way
and i my understanding from looking at
these clips
is that jimmy dore the interviews are
edited it's all edited
so i guess this i mean he hasn't aired
any of this
i think because it looks so terrible but
i guess the plan was to cut that out but
i i would
never treat a guest like i mean it's it
it actually is indicative of an of
an emotional disturbance that's pretty
serious you talk about what we're
talking about i asked you about the
boogaloo boys and you start telling me
what i should be doing with tucker
carlson all right
well then let's go let's go directly to
his twitter threads um and
and all this stuff what about all this
stuff from magnus talking about his
support of kyle rittenhouse
dude i'm i'm asking you about
the boogaloo boys and what you know
about them
okay so so if what the adl is saying is
correct is what the adl saying is that
correct
what i know about uh this particular
boogaloo boy magnus panvidya
in his own words on twitter uh he's
talking about his support of kyle
rittenhouse
and um it's a hill that he's willing to
die on uh when asked whether
he's you know he's he's left to right
and and whether blm
is more important uh than what happened
with written house uh he says
uh you know he'll die on that hill the
ridden house hill and he says i choose
both slash shrug um
i mean there is some merit to what
people are are talking about
okay so so that guy in particular he
you're saying that that guy in
particular is a defender of kyle
rittenhouse
correct okay
all right and so and kyle rittenhouse
was the guy
was it wisconsin yeah
oh boy the kenosha wisconsin yeah the
kenosha shooter
yeah and who did and he and he killed
who did he kill
okay uh then rod weber links to the
unicorn riot piece and i see people
telling me that this has now been
published with some edits after this all
went live so
rod weber links to the unicorn riot
piece um
and uh let's let's watch a little bit
more of this
the kyle rittenhouse support is
problematic to a lot of lefties it's
like saying
oh we're going to get together with
charles manson oh okay but he wrote some
beach boys songs you know
okay okay okay that makes sense rod
that makes sense yeah i would have a
problem with that too
yeah yeah that's a pro that's a big
problem right yeah
for sure seems very unstable
very very unstable so so what so then
what do we do
what do we do when a guy like that shows
up with someone from antifa and black
lives matter
and claims all the things he claims what
what what do we do
with that guy do we not talk to i mean
you've talked to those well i say it's
on a case-by-case basis
and um what we need to do is is vet them
more
you know before putting them that you're
guessing the internet uh you know the
tons of people
to let them just say what they want to
say unchecked yeah
this is what's called responsible
platforming like you know what i try to
do when i interview people like richard
spencer and others which is i research
them to figure out what have they said
what are their positions etc
people had a problem with you not
pushing back on these particular issues
uh when boogaloo comes up you know the
first thing that i'm looking up
is is i i did a search across search of
magnus panvidya
and kyle rittenhouse boom there it's
coming right up
so when you would okay uh
so we saw so i saw a video of him
calling for unity
and so we reached out to him to
interview him and i interviewed him and
my jaw was on the floor yeah and so a
lot of people
and so and so then we and then a lot of
folks say no jimmy that guy's lying to
you
right so then i go to the adl and i look
up the adl and they
they say no that guy's not lying to you
they actually support black lives matter
now this issue of him continuing to
mention the adl is interesting and we'll
get back to that
uh and they're anti and they're not
racist so but then you and then you say
that
on on twitter he supports kyle
rittenhouse and so that
if i if i'm going to put something like
that in a documentary i'm going to make
sure that there's strong pushback
against that
how would i even know to google that
that's the key
i mean like what how exactly do i search
for things about the people i'm going to
be interviewing well you start by
putting their name in i mean that's
that's the first part you put their name
into google
i even know the google boogaloo boy you
know what i mean like
i wouldn't like if i didn't you know
again if i went to look up boogaloo boys
and i went to adl
it would say the opposite and so i
wouldn't i've since
seen that people say oh no on twitter
he's talking about kyle
well how would i i'd say follow daryl
lamont jenkins f
f
his latest movie is called 2020 the
dumpster fire
when he scrawled on the wall of okay so
um then there's you know
read through the thread rod then puts
together a lot of different information
which i think
is is important um then this part is
very interesting
uh jimmy dore berated me about the
importance of platforming people you
know nothing about i replied it's not a
good idea his uh his eyes reveal he
knows he's he's effed up okay let's
listen
i'm gonna bring out an even more of an
expert our guest is an artist and
talented documentarian
his films include the war of north
dakota and flowers for peace
so i had no you know i i i i
had no idea about the kyle rittenhouse
thing uh when i interviewed that guy
i was just interviewing him and taking
him at face value and i was pushing back
i'm like
you're supposed to you're not anti-gay
you're not acting that pushback was not
real pushback i actually saw that
interview it was satirical pushback it
was
so you're not homophobic oh like it was
not
actual pushback it was it was almost the
opposite it was almost mocking anybody
who would have believed the boogaloo guy
might have or anyone associated with
google who might have those views
so uh and then i also said i i don't
know anything about this
this group the fact that we're making it
toxic
uh for americans to talk to other
americans right we're in this moment now
when our government is abandoning us
and we all know that there might be a
civil war coming
it's more important now than ever to
talk to people because of coven
because we're all being screwed by the
government
it's more important to talk to uh it's
called class consciousness so do you
what you don't recommend i i'm pretty
sure you don't recommend that
some of our people in our same class
it's crazy to say that
class consciousness means that if you
are of a certain economic class
you must platform anyone else of the
same economic click i don't even
understand the coherence of that
argument
we don't talk to right you don't
recommend that right i i recommend that
a lot of this talking uh be done in
private i'm not saying that that there
aren't ways to
publicly do some of these discussions uh
but it has to be done in a careful
fashion so be scared to talk to people i
got it
you know you got to be scared that's not
what he's saying though
that's not being afraid because people
are going to twist your words
and they're going to spit so you got to
be super scared and let's make sure
nobody talks to each other on air so
nobody gets to know what the other
side's about if you talk to players just
do it one-on-one
and never do it again uh no i disagree
that's a bad idea what's he talking
about that's not but so we'll disagree
on
we definitely disagree on that yeah so
it's super important to talk to people
yeah you should and and
and the idea that we should be afraid to
do it on camera
uh is cowardly so i'm not going to do
that i'm not afraid to talk to them on
camera
those are your words there it's not a
good idea to put them on camera when
you're not
it's just called responsible platforming
is all this is this is i'm not i don't
want to pretend like it's
uncontroversial
but you know over the last decade doing
doing the show
this is ground we've we've walked over a
bunch of times it's just called
responsible platforming
you haven't researched them well and
you're not giving pushback on the
correct points
okay okay point taken that's why i got
you here rod
i wouldn't you know that and so uh so
when it
when it's ready uh come back let me know
and i'd love to have you back on and
we'll talk about it
okay all right so we'll continue then
there is
uh let's see okay this is interesting
this is during the setup phase and it
actually you recognize even though jimmy
keeps talking about the adl
it's clear here he doesn't know what the
adl is
jimmy will walk across he usually speaks
to the cameras straight here
interviewed a guy and and the corporate
left comes at me
exactly the way they come after glenn
greenwald matt tybee
chris hedges anybody who's doing good
work that's what they'll do
true so if you're if your film is good
you will be smeared
the cia had my sixth i got them all
coming at me
the cia the mi6 i've got them all coming
after me
now you know it's it's hard to prove a
negative
it's it's hard for any of us to say it's
definitely not
true that the cia and mi6
are coming after jimmy dore
um but that's that's that's quite a
statement to make
and this is when for me it starts to
become
pretty clear that you know there there
may be a little something
something else going on here um
cia and mi6 it's you know let's look a
little bit a little bit more
they're [ __ ] editing my wikipedia
page they're writing hit pieces at
newsweek and cnn
sorry mr door
there you go you might have to come down
a little bit jimmy
steph does lint control as well yes she
does
so everybody knows i did an interview
with a self-described libertarian
boogaloo boy
and i was unbelievably surprised at the
stuff he was saying like for instance
here it is
okay well i was told that matter of fact
i'm not the most straight man myself
so so that was my jaw was on the floor
when i heard that guy say that stuff
because i had the exact opposite opinion
of those people i thought they were all
racists and they were all anti-gay
anti-black lives matter for sure i
thought but
uh turns out he was saying the opposite
and i got a i was called the white
supremacist for just interviewing that
guy i was called i was boosting him
just because i interviewed him because
that's what corporate democrats like to
do
um and i did what so i went to the uh uh
the adl right the associate uh
the um the [ __ ] does adls did
american def what is this american
defense league i don't know the american
nobody knows of course it's the
anti-defamation league but
so why i just
i can't donation league that's what that
is right
i'm trying to find it anti-defamation
yeah that's it anti-defamation
okay so mike make the make the necessary
edit so i don't look like the idiot that
i am
thank you so this is from the adl the
anti-defamation league
okay so you guys you guys get the point
of this
it's really really weird and it sort of
renews my thought that
that something something's not quite
right i mean the cia mi6 stuff is
it's it's pretty out there it's pretty
out there so that's
that's my thought there all right so
that's the jimmy door thing and
make of it make of it what you will a
big thank you to tsk
uh quabity yeshuans funky kurt ukrainian
tacos
and many others who signed up via twitch
in fact
six of you did putting us at 38. i
also want to say thanks to some folks
who signed up on my website
alison plittman thank you so much
and michael carroll who signed up at
joinedpakman.com
we've got a couple more things to go
through and then if we do get to 100
i'll open up the
the discord lines and hear from some
people all right before we do the mike
lindell stuff let's do
i have a couple of voicemails these are
more voicemails from
troy york i know the audience is mixed
about whether to do
troy york stuff or not but it's i'm not
doing it on the broadcast show
but it's entertaining enough i think for
uh for some of the live streams
so let's take a listen to one this is
troy york calling in his wally jackson
yeah mark it down this is uh wally
jackson calling to dave peckman show
i just want to mark it down that um
on february 4th at 3 15
um david pakman has produced his first
propaganda video
uh vlog and attack
uh now that trump is no longer around uh
on jim jordan uh david pakman's in
argentina israeli rotten troll
hates america and thus anyone who
promotes
a strong value american uh
policy and politics and culture such as
the congressman from ohio's
fifth this district trip jordan
is someone who a scumbag like david
pakman
would basically consider an enemy of the
globalist cause
hold on a second i thought i thought i
was one of the globalists which just
means
jews now i'm an enemy of the globe i'm
under or or oh
oh oh i would consider jim jordan an
enemy of the globalists which means the
jews is that what he means
this is why david pakman hates rush
limbaugh
um pat robertson because you're
christian
i don't really hate them i just find
them to be very dumb
donald trump who david pakman mentioned
uh for the last 890 days straight
in his obsessive compulsive desire and
lust for
mr trump uh this is why david hank
pacman hates michael savage
now that's not a name i've thought about
for a long time michael savage
much um this is why david pakman hated
mark levine
okay so i'm gonna sk this is funny it
times out like he goes the full three
minutes and then gets cut so let's
listen to the last 20 seconds to hear
where it gets cut
yeah we'll defeat the corrupt dictator
in waiting um with his stupid face name
80 year old joe biden that's so easy to
forget if he's still alive
jim jordan is likely to be the next
donald trump or along with josh hawley
okay so then that was just cut there i
like josh howley also
then uh because the art you can only
leave a three minute message
and then i think he called back
immediately this was at five a.m
this morning um and left another three
minute voicemail
hey david hackman this is wally jackson
again calling back
i just want to let you know i commented
on your youtube channel
where you had where you
mentioned to attack jim jordan and i
think it's a joke that someone like you
who has no integrity
and all you have is total audacity i
have total
unfettered unmitigated audacity
attack this great patriots jim jordan
and you lie about him you are
propagandist
you are jealous this man represents
people he's an elected
official yeah i'm really jealous of jim
jordan
that's michelle you can get elected to
town jerk off in jacksonville you are a
loser
it's it may be true that in jacksonville
i might not be able to get elected
that's probably true
you couldn't get you could never get
elected to even the
library board in yonkers you younkers i
might be able to
yonkers actually i might have a shot you
are a complete
fabricator you're jealous of jim jordan
and again
you call him the vile disgusting
individual but i think in order to
see a real vile disgusting rotten
individual as you described
congressman jim jordan uh you all right
look
into a mirror or maybe your phone when
it's off
you can see your own reflection so yeah
troy york seems wasted out of his mind
i mean he was calling at 4 00 a.m his
time
so make of that what you will and then
that might be
it hold on did i have any others
no that's it okay no the other one yeah
that's it so there's there's our
voicemails uh
voicemails from from troy york so we've
got those out of the way
and a big thank you to marco stolba for
signing up at
joinpackman.com let's look at a few
super chats did he just say
wtf does the adl stand for how is he on
left youtube also sounds paranoid
yes very much so senator richard c
shelby of alabama he does not intend to
run for reelection
interesting when do you think you may go
back on the line with matt dillahunty
really looking forward to that unsure
i agree with destiny on the written
house situation probably innocent of
murder
innocent is not the right word the legal
system adjudicates guilt or lack of
guilt so i think whenever you introduce
a term like innocent
you confuse things i also agree with
jimmy in this video so far
ajc has a story about marjorie green's
gun in school story she wasn't part of
the hostage group and may actually have
been cutting class
that's incredible tiffany says david i
finally got a job and promised you a
super chat when i did so here you go
thanks for getting
me through 2020. thank you
um super chat was referencing billy
madison it's a well-known quote we want
you to watch willie
billy madison okay all right thank you
very much i will uh
i will look into that all right let's
get to the my pillow guy
the my pillow guy mike lindell uh had
teased that
today he was going to be giving us all
sorts of information about voter fraud
and everything else
i guess it started with a uh with a very
big disclaimer let's take a look
michael james lindell has purchased the
air time for the broadcast of this
program on
one america news network mr lindell is
the sole
author and executive producer of this
program and
is solely and exclusively responsible
yeah this is quite a this is quite a
disclaimer the topic of this broadcast
is the 2020 election oen has undertaken
its own reporting on this topic
this program is not the product of oan's
reporting
the views opinions and claims expressed
this program
by mr lindell and other guests
presenters producers or apps
yeah so basically this is an
advertisement
all right we get it let's go on to the
first clip here
miracles that happened these last couple
months the first miracle was on election
night
and on election night at 11 15 at night
the the algorithms of these machines
broke
basically this will be explained hold on
the algorithms broke oh that is rich
this is too good
algorithms of these machines broke
basically broke
and all this will be explained during
this show i like how he says they broke
and then he says they basically broke
but they broke what that means is donald
trump got
so many more millions of votes that they
didn't expect
that they had they're going to have to
go recalibrate right
so that's why that's not how voting
machines work
yeah so there was an algorithm which
was expecting a certain amount of votes
and then so many votes came in
that the algorithm had to be
recalibrated
uh all right let's continue this is a
lot a whole program but i can't subject
people to that
so we're just doing aaron rupar from vox
did some of the highlights for us
the winner but here's the big thing the
big miracle
if they would have done that if they
would have done that
and said you know what we can't count
these
mr trump wins donald trump wins okay
then we wouldn't be where we're at right
now
because the biggest thing against
humanity
and our country is this attack
through these machines they got this
opened up this revealed
the the machines to where we're at right
now so what you're going to watch during
this show
is 100 percent proof it is
infomercial-like and that he keeps
saying
all of the stuff is coming up it's
coming it's coming okay
that the big thing was the theft
by these other countries that came in to
attack our country
through these machines that are made to
steal
elections every election going forward
in history if these things would have
happened these elections
going forward in history
i mean hold on i this is almost like a
sci-fi thing now
every election going forward in history
that doesn't make sense right that can't
possibly make sense
and we wouldn't we would have never
known every single vote you would have
ever made
won the matter somebody else would have
made that vote
and we've all seen this past month you
think it was a communist coming in and
taking this over
with people here this is an attack not
only on other
those other countries with communism but
it's an attack
on the countries with communism
we had domestic traders right here in
our country
whatever's going on right now we're
seeing it they're suppressing cancer
culture
they're trying they're suppressing
cancer culture or they're
executing cancer culture trying to
cancel us
all out i just seen churches the
christian church
they're being attacked right now people
on social media anyone that speaks up
they're going you can't say that you're
gone it's like they're right now they're
doing whack-a-mole because they know
they knew they were so close so close
that we would never know and hit this is
really really nuts i guess then here he
brings on a guest of some kind
uh let's see the money on the front side
to make sure the election was gone
the same thing with china if china could
avoid
the us coming to taiwan's defense and
we've seen indications of that already
and if china could avoid having to fight
a campaign
to protect their man-made islands to
extend their territorial waters into
international navigable waterways if
they could invest
does it does it seem like mike pillow is
understanding this stuff
billion dollars to do that versus
fighting a war
well they've made a pretty good
investment and all the money that
they've uh made into the biden family
um all the money that they've made and
invested into
u.s universities and u.s businesses
buying up
our medical and our technical
intellectual property
stealing a lot more than they bought
they
are they are fighting a war and people
just don't realize that we're under
attack
so now we have wow okay so then uh
mike lindell makes up the word cyberly
here we go uh and you're saying
that 27 states use this and the servers
are overseas
so these can go over there and they can
change the vote
to anything they want and send it back
cyberly
oh that is beautiful they sent it back
they didn't send it over cyberly
but they sent it back cyberly
correct anything they want and send it
back cyberly
by cyber buy cyber yeah it was sent by
cyber
um okay let's see if there's any more
this is really rich stuff
okay so where were we cyberly is here um
all right let's look at another one this
is really really nuts
and they began to try to have a series
of classified briefings within
their own group in order to push this
up up the chain and they got about one
or two levels up
and then they met a solid wall of
resistance that basically said leave it
alone don't
pursue it is this eric coomer right here
wow and what do you what do you think
being now now we're
here telling the facts on the show here
but in your mind why would they do that
what this is just subjectively why would
why would you why would they do that in
your mind
i don't know mine you can't explain it i
mean this is
okay so so then so take us from there so
this is like uh
what what what approximately when was
that when it this is pretty convincing
stuff
um okay i guess that's
that is that that is out of this world
crazy that it does really really nuts
uh let me see what people are saying
denver mccarthy says i was skeptical
about the claims mike lindell is making
but the ominous background music
convinced me it's real you cannot make a
good faith argument against that music
david
fair adam says he deliberately misspoke
so it will hold up in court
cody says i think what he's trying to
say is that the supposed algorithm
that dynamically adjusts votes to ensure
a rigged democrat win
couldn't keep up all right oh i see yeah
the algorithm was supposed to be
stealing votes from trump at one rate
but it was going too crazy so then it
had to be
modified to steal even more votes um
communist machines went back in time
through the singularity to election
night at 11 15 pm for the great miracle
to stop president trump who is a robot
david is this documentary three hours
long you can't convince me my
mike pillow isn't back on the crack rock
wow another crazy person do you think
the pillow guy believes what he is
saying
that's a good question you know people
asked earlier whether marjorie taylor
green
believes the things she's saying and i
believe the answer is yes
i actually don't know with mike pillow
whether
he believes the thing he's the things
he's saying i'm not sure
i'm leaning towards yes but i'm not
completely sure
oh no eric roth's child just cheered a
hundred bits on twitch
marjorie taylor green is not going to
like that she believes it's the
rothschilds which is code for jews
controlling the space
laser that is not going to sit well with
marjorie taylor green
david will your show be available
cyberly soon it will it will be
available via cyber
his pillows are filled with the tears of
the ghost of hugo chavez
concerned that the music is for
hypnotism it may be
this guy makes alex jones look like a
pulitzer prize winner
well said um it's funny that they have
to add the ominous music in the
background to invoke some
sort of feeling of skepticism yeah very
much well said
very very much well said uh i do want to
say thanks to
i godder and gt jefe
who have signed up via twitch
putting us at 43
and then also want to say thanks to
alejandra
vilchis who signed up at joinpakman.com
putting us
at 44. so i was going to open up some
phone lines at a hundred i don't know if
we're going to get there
um and that's sad i guess but it's
something
something to think about as far as next
week goes here's what i wanted to ask
people about
tuesday the um
impeachment trial of donald trump the
next impeachment trial of donald trump
starts
would people prefer that we stream the
entire thing
and i'm only there for part of it and we
just run the stream
all day or because i have to film my
regular show
right so i can't be there all day or
should i just do
like a two-hour session at some point
when we're not recording the show
what do people think
some people seem to be misunderstanding
the two choices
yikes uh okay
a lot of people seem to say just run the
stream all day and come in and out okay
we could probably do that
that's not a bad idea
yeah maybe we'll do that then okay yeah
it's no problem i mean i think it's it's
all the same really from the from the
standpoint of technical
it's all uh and i'll be in for a couple
of hours throughout
a few people are saying don't show the
whole thing but i think i think we
should
just run it so people can stay on the
stream yeah all right uh i don't know
what time it's starting i assume it's
like 9 or 10 a.m or something like that
so we will um we will see
all right that's gonna do it for me
today we had a lot of stuff to get
through we got through
all of it and i will be right back with
everybody on monday or soon or if major
news should break thanks for joining me